General nyas Julius Agricola stood on
the wet Heather at the very edge of
humanity
it was beginning to rain and a misty
drizzle was being carried Inland on the
saline air
This truly was a Savage place
a place where the gods had not worked
their benevolence as they had on his
Mediterranean home
he looked out across the Deep Waters of
the outer edge of the Known World The
Campaign was over but Agricola had one
last command to undertake after four
Decades of sporadic conquest and
numerous setbacks the Roman army was
poised to enter the highlands of
Northern Caledonia to wipe out the
remaining native resistance and
determine the limits of Europe
Agricola would go on to confirm that the
British landmass was an Island by
navigating unfamiliar Seas exploring
undiscovered coastlines and making
contact with previously unknown peoples
the leader of these people the one they
called The Swordsman had said that
Beyond these Shores lay only rocks
see that was probably true but as he
watched the rain clouds roll back over
the Northwestern Sunset Agricola
wandered
he cast his mind back 30 years to when
Emperor Claudius had just begun his
conquest of Britain Agricola had been a
young student at masalia ancient
Marseille a Greek founded city under
Roman rule it was respected center of
learning with a prominent statue of the
legendary Greek Seafarer pythius four
centuries earlier in the time of
Alexander the Great pythius had entered
the Atlantic and explored the furthest
limits of the ocean Beyond Britain
but he had claimed to have seen a
further great landmass positioned far
beyond it was his belief that three vast
items formed the North Atlantic Isles
Britain Ireland
and Thor
pythius states that he set foot on every
part of Britain he also gives an account
of Thule and describes a region where he
says the land sea and air are no longer
separate elements instead there is a
thick compound resembling a sea lung
which suspends itself over ocean and
land merging and binding Elemental
matter this material cannot be traveled
over or sailed through
[Music]
in the long half-light before the first
Stars appeared Agricola looked out at
the darkening Horizon was the legendary
island of Ultima Thule out there at the
very rim of the globe where daylight
lingered
and so he mused to himself if he'd come
this far
why not go further
beneath him the Roman Fleet had
reassembled in a deep Inlet to Shelter
From a sudden Autumn storm the war
galleys and support vessels were making
ready to range northward along the
furthest seaboards of Caledonia they
would support the legions who were
pushing forward into the highlands and
forests Agricola watched as the ships
shifted on an incoming tide
he would have told his fleet commander
what to expect out there
Roman knowledge of the North Sea
suggested the latitudes Beyond Britain
would be subject to horrendous storms
carrying Frozen currents and biting cold
winds from the far north
Beyond Britain the sea became cold and
began to solidify this process began
with the platelets of floating sea ice
that resembled a Shoal of encroaching
jellyfish
the cold increased these ice plates
merged into sheets that could immobilize
then Crush Timber vessels
Agricola had seen with his own eyes the
white mass of a Caledonian Sea Mist
hanging over an early Frost
truly a compound resembling a sea lung
as pythius had claimed some four
centuries prior
and so with the Roman military about to
encounter Ultima Thule
would the Roman explorers sent out by
Agricola soon Shred the beaches of this
remote mysterious and semi-mythical land
but of course this was not the first
time that the Romans had explored beyond
the limits of the known world or cross
the boundaries of knowledge
a long sequence of Adventure conquest
and ambition had led Rome and its armies
far beyond the familiar
to the boundaries of the unknown
centuries of expansion had pushed the
Eternal City to the ends of the Earth
not only to the far north but far east
west and south too
answer this
is that story
this is the story of the edges
of the empire
the Roman soldiers diet was mainly wheat
some sources tell us that salt was
surprised that soldiers in the Republic
were paid in salt and this was the root
of the word salary this video has been
sponsored by facta the best healthiest
meal delivery service out there and
something that those legionaries would
probably have appreciated personally
facta is great for saving me from my
terrible Vice of unhealthy takeaway food
factors healthy menus are updated weekly
and include more than 27 meals and 33
add-on options you can choose your
favorite meals or let facto crafter
order based on your taste preference and
meal history they offer keto calorie
smart Chef's Choice and vegan and veggie
options it's an amazing time saver and
meal plans range from 4 to 18 meals per
week so you can add more or reduce the
number depending on your specific needs
you can even skip a week if you need to
your meal is delivered fresh never
Frozen directly to your door just heat
eat and enjoy so head to factor75.com or
click the link below to use code voice
50 and get 50 off your first Factor box
thanks to factor for supporting history
content on YouTube
in the 3rd Century BC the embattled
Roman state was largely confined to
Italy with a powerful network of Italian
city-state allies but in the century
that followed proud Legions captured and
subdued Macedonia seized the prosperous
island of Sicily and laid claim to
territories in eastern Spain
and finally after generations of
persistent rivalry and warfare they
closed in on the already beaten and
believed good carthaginians on the coast
of North Africa following a three-year
Siege the Monumental conflict between
these two opposing Empires was at last
concluded
the Roman general Scipio emilianos
oversaw the final brutal capture and
destruction of the seaport of Carthage
he gave orders that the Roman army
should burn destroy and demolish
everything in their path during six days
of savage fighting in the city streets
the order was repeatedly given
clear the thoroughfares
wounded and dying citizens were dragged
away and heaped along with corpses and
debris from collapsing buildings
then both living and dead bodies were
cast into pits filled with rubble and
other charred remains Appian writes to
make the streets possible they cleared
the debris with axes matocks and pronged
tools with these iron instruments the
dead and the living were rolled and
dragged along like debris before being
hurled together into pits The Trenches
were filled with the dead and still
living
finally over 50 000 traumatized
survivors who had taken refuge in an
inner Citadel surrendered they were
secured in the iron chains of the Roman
slave dealers
surrounded by his closest advisors
Scipio oversaw this final destruction of
the city from a distant Vantage Point as
the ruins of Carthage smoldered down to
Embers and Ashes Scipio is said to have
suddenly stood very still
in quiet reflection
the battle
was over
the threat of death was gone and the
thrill of killing had subsided
became lost in thought was this the
ultimate Destiny of all Empires
Appian records Scipio behelds the final
destruction of a city which had
flourished 700 years from its foundation
it had ruled over so many lands islands
and seas it had been prosperous with
great armies and fleets elephants and
wealth of money it had been equal to the
mightiest monarchies but surpassed them
all in bravery and ambition
now the city had met its end in a final
and complete destruction
Scipio beholding this spectacle is said
to have shed tears and publicly demented
the destiny of his enemy
a Greek advisor called polybius who was
standing nearby overheard Scipio muttera
quote from Homer a verse from The Iliad
concerning the destruction of the
legendary city of Troy
the great campaign was over
but what next
perhaps thought polybius a new Odyssey
was about to begin
Olivia's turned his back on the Broken
City and looked out towards the sea
where new possibilities awaited
could he become a new
Odysseus
Rome was Victorious Carthage was gone
and its possessions in North Africa were
now the property of the expanding Roman
Empire the sea Lanes leading into the
Atlantic was suddenly open to Roman
shipping but what unknown lands lay
beyond the Mediterranean and the fabled
pillars of Hercules
Scipio was determined to destroy all
remnants of Carthage and this included
its diaspora the carthaginians had
established small colonies and trade
stations on the Arid outer shores of
North Africa modern-day Morocco had
these Atlantic connections provided the
carthaginians with their great wealth
and good fortune perhaps so Scipio
offered his Greek advisor polybius
command of several Roman War galleys and
instructed him to find the westward
limits of carthaginian power
and so his journey West
began
by following the African Coast polybius
passed the high Atlas mountain range and
prepared to enter the Atlantic but he
was crossing through more than a
physical limitation he was intruding
into the domain of gods myths Heroes and
monsters deities always existed where
practical experience faltered and common
knowledge Ended as they passed into
Uncharted regions polybius and his small
Fleet like Odysseus repaired themselves
for Supernatural hazards as well as
physical dangers
[Music]
to begin with it was said that the
world-bearing Titan Atlas held the
weight of the sky on his shoulders
indeed the fossilized remains of this
Godlike giant might yet be seen in the
high Atlas Mountains perhaps its massive
form would be glimpsed as a vast
Mountain column projecting upwards far
beyond the tallest Peaks the Romans
strained their eyes looking Inland at
the ranges to discern the shape or form
of the primordial Titan
at the edge of the Mediterranean a high
cliff-like Promontory Hove interview on
the European Coast this was the Rock of
Gibraltar which formed one flank of the
legendary pillars of Hercules the
Gateway between the Mediterranean and
the Atlantic
it was said that the legendary demigod
Hercules had cut a channel through a
mountain to join the Seas and enter the
Atlantic though other accounts suggested
Hercules had merely fortified an
existing sea passage so the giant
Oceanic monsters might not stray into
the peaceful Mediterranean this raw
human passage was the Strait through
which polybius and his ships now passed
oh as he passed this legendary spot
polybius must have considered the
reports of his Greek forebears who had
themselves heard second-hand accounts
from carthaginians seafarers for it had
been in the 6th Century BC that a
carthaginian commander named Hano the
Navigator had voyaged beyond the pillars
of Hercules and explored the Western
Seaboard of the African continent Hano
had left an account of his voyage this
had been translated into Greek and
circulated among Roman authorities in an
abbreviated form it was said that Hannah
had commanded a settler Fleet intended
to colonize distant regions but south of
Morocco the carthaginians had
encountered only a bleak and hostile
Coastline the Greek writer Aryan read
the translated report as Hano sailed
South he encountered crippling obstacles
a lack of water scorching heat and
streams of lava gushing into the sea
perhaps these explorers had sailed
beyond the southern limit of the vast
Sahara Desert and witnessed volcanic
lava spilling into the sea at Mount
Cameroon
even more terrifying with the human-like
creatures encountered in the region Hano
had reported this Lagoon was another
Island full of savages most of them were
women with hairy bodies whom our
interpreters called gorillas although we
chased them we could not catch any males
they all escaped since they were good
climbers and could defend themselves
with stones however we caught three
women they refused to follow those who
carried them off biting and clawing at
them so he killed them and flayed them
and brought their skins back to Carthage
we could not sail any further because
our Provisions were running short
these pelt-like skins had been taken to
Carthage and hung as Curiosities in the
temple of the Goddess tanet Macabre
trophies lingering on as a testament to
a strange never to be repeated voyage
for almost four centuries the hides had
hung silently in the shrine until the
destruction of Carthage when the Romans
looted the city and burnt the sacred
Temple
by contrast the temperate shores of
Western Europe were explored by
carthaginian Merchants who sailed to
distant northern islands in pursuit of
valuable resources somewhere out in the
Atlantic Ocean were trade routes to the
distant Isle of Albion and irony the
Celtic peoples of Southern Britain
supplied essential tin which was alloyed
with commonly found copper to produce
sturdy bronze metal other strange
materials reached the Mediterranean
through these Atlantic Sea veins
including valuable Baltic Amber this was
thought to be the congealed rays of the
Setting Sun sometimes strange tropical
insects could be seen in the solidified
Center of this highly desirable
substance perhaps they were evidence of
an Undiscovered tropical Zone in the far
away Frozen North
and so it was that after the destruction
of Carthage Scipio sent out his small
exploratory Roman Fleet commanded by
polybius
passing cautiously through the pillars
of Hercules they sailed South around the
coast of Morocco the Roman writer Pliny
the Elder records after sailing around
the coast polybius reported that in a
Westerly Direction Beyond Mount atlas
there are forests teeming with wild
animals that Africa produces Beyond this
is the river non which is full of
crocodiles and hippopotami from the non
there is a line of mountains going right
up to a high peak that the Greeks call
The Chariot of the Gods
with their greatest rival Carthage
removed from Power the Romans had
finally reached the Western Gateway of
the Mediterranean and entered the
Atlantic Ocean the coastal ports of
Western Ghoul Now within their reach a
new direction for exploration contact
and Conquest had been revealed
The Roots the Roman Fortune were now
opened into the West
but this
was just the beginning
[Music]
in another region of the ancient world
another leading general of the Roman
Republic was also suddenly overcome by
emotion at its very moment of supreme
victory
nayas pompeus Magnus Pompey the great
stood in shock as he was presented with
a semi-embarked corpse of his Royal
enemy mithridates
those given the task of preserving the
Royal remains had failed to remove the
brain tissue and the putrid objects set
before him filled Pompey with a deep
revulsion nevertheless one of the
greatest foes the Romans had ever faced
was dead
pompey's grand campaigned for vengeance
exploration and Conquest
was over
[Music]
the year was 65 BC and yet another great
Kingdom had fallen to the rising power
of Rome and its Relentless Legions
the pontic king mithridates VI had been
betrayed by his allies and subjects in
the Crimean Kingdom of the Sumerian
Bosphorus this had been his last refuge
and the King had ended his own life
rather than suffer humiliation as a
captive in Rome in his pursuit of Mithra
deities Pompey the great had entered the
Caucasus Mountains passed through the
dark forests of culcus and explored the
snow-capped mountains between the
turbulent Black Sea and the Mysterious
Caspian region now that the arch enemy
of Rome was dead the general reflected
on the extraordinary discoveries he had
made in these Far Eastern territories
the heavily forested territory of caucus
on the west coast of the Black Sea had
always been a dangerous and largely
unknown region A wilderness Zone where
tall dense forests fringed mountain
ranges near where the Rioni River
emptied into the Black Sea was an
ancient Greek Harbor Town named fasis a
Frontier Trading Outpost that retained
its wild and dangerous character
throughout Antiquity statues of
classical Gods stood in the harbor and
Town Center displaying the strange
influence of barbaric local Cults the
site was a hub for numerous merchants
and fugitives who mingled with guides
translators and dubious representatives
from the nearby Mountain tribes and so
it was fasis that it served as the outer
limit of the furthest Greek voyages
indeed not even Alexander the Great who
dared to enter this region this meant
culcus was the subject of long-standing
myth and Legend once again a region
thought to encroach on the realm of the
Gods many in Rome must have wondered
what did Pompey found out there at the
limits of the known world
Greek myth had long warned of the
dangers of exceeding human knowledge
contrary to the will of the Gods
it was said that the Titan Prometheus
had fashioned Mankind from clay giving
his creation thought and reason but this
primeval deity had suffered Eternal
punishment for giving his prodigies the
key to technology and understanding of
Fire
on the orders of Zeus Prometheus had
supposedly been chained to a rock in the
furthest reaches of the Caucasus
Mountains bound on a high mountain peak
a Giant Eagle descended each day to tear
out the innards of the helpless immortal
ancient caucus was too immortalized in
the story of Jason and the Argonauts who
sought the Golden Fleece in this
forbidding region
accounts of gold dust and giant dragon
serpents filled the minds of Greek
writers regarding these unexplored
mountains the main anchor from Jason's
ship the Argo was on display in the
center of fasis as a monument to the
ancient myth some visitors doubted the
authenticity of this object since it was
made of relatively unwithered iron but
these Skeptics were shown fragments of
an older Stone object that better fitted
the Antiquity of the myth
and so this was the place where King
Mithra deities had fled to Rally his
tribal allies against Rome
and this was where Pompey had to follow
to defeat his great enemy
but Pompey was also eager to lead his
soldiers into a land of myth and Legend
according to Appian Pompey wanted to
gain knowledge of the country visited by
the Argonauts Castor and Pollux and
Hercules he is specially desired to see
the place where they say that Prometheus
was fastened to mount Caucasus
from the pontic kingdom Pompey marched
on and invaded the small Kingdom of
Caucasian Iberia caucus was now cut off
from Armenia and Iran but Pompey did not
push onwards to the coast of the
mysterious Caspian Sea instead he headed
Inland to find the Rioni River and
capture the port city of fasis
this connected him with the Roman Fleet
operating in the Black Sea but once more
he discovered that Mithra deities had
fled
pompey's thought of pursuing The
Fugitive with the Roman Fleet and
sailing past Mount strobius where
Prometheus had been trained by Zeus
would a Roman general dare look upon the
sight where the creator of mankind had
withstood his eternal punishment
but suddenly a new plan entered the mind
of Pompey he realized that he would only
retain his command while Mithra deities
remained a threat to Rome
while the defeated King was confined to
the far north the near East was exposed
to immediate Roman Conquest
[Music]
Plutarch reports
Pompey was seized by a great and eager
passion to claim Syria and marched
through Arabia to the Red Sea his
Victorious career would therefore touch
the ocean which surrounds the world on
all sides for in Africa he'd been the
first to conquer as far as the outer sea
and in Spain he had made the Atlantic
Ocean the western boundary of the Roman
domains
so now Pompey put his army in motion
determined to reach the Red Sea and
completes the circuit of his military
expeditions
Pompey marched South with his Legions
seizing Syria and making the kingdom of
Judea subject to the Roman Empire in
Jerusalem a Pompey and his Entourage
entered the Great temple of the one true
God of the Jews they ignored all appeals
and threats by the priests and defied
the holy law by gazing upon the
artifacts of the Lord his as his men
held back the protesting high priest
Pompey inhaled the heavy scent of
hallowed incense and stepped forward to
vanish behind the veil that covered the
darkness of the inner Sanctuary his
soldiers waited for the general to
reappear with the idol of the Lord God
Almighty of the Jews would he smash it
before the distraught priests or carry
it back to be mocked in a great
triumphal procession through the streets
of Rome
time passed
ignore it immediately reappear Josephus
records that Pompey simply examined the
artifacts preserved in that Holy place
but removed nothing
he reappeared empty-handed and then
departed in silence
where Pompey continued the March South
the nabataean kingdom in Northwest
Arabia was next to submit to Rome and
the legions were encamped near the
rock-cut City of Petra all the threats
of divine curses and catastrophes had
proven false and the near East was now
under Imperial control
the region belonged to Rome and the
outer sea was within their grasp but the
campaign led by Pompey had far exceeded
its objectives this was irrefutable when
news reached him that mithridates was
already dead there had been an uprising
in the Sumerian Bosphorus and the King
had ended his life as a final escape
from the Pursuits of the Romans
the war was done
Pompey received the messengers and was
presented with the semi-embalmed corpse
of his enemy but the general chose not
to look upon the putrid remains or
reflect upon this man's great fall from
Regal power and Glory
for it was now he realized that the
exploratory aspect of his mission must
also cease
Pompey had failed to encounter any
monsters or meet any living divinities
in the distant Caucasus but at farsis
the Romans did find Indian Commodities
among the goods trafficked over land
from the Caspian Sea these Indian Goods
came from bactria by the auxus river to
the Caspian coasts
Pompey had discovered a possible route
to India that could bypass Iran and the
Rival parthian Empire but who amongst
ordinary merchants and travelers would
dare Traverse this route through distant
and dangerous lands
not Pompey
fifteen years later he finally met his
fate in the east
defeated by Julius Caesar in the Roman
Civil Wars the dejected General was
betrayed by his own officers and
murdered
when his severed head was presented to
Caesar the dictator too turned away in
disgust and horror despite the political
conflict Caesar mourned the loss of his
former friend and colleague
from that moment on it would be Caesar
and his dynasty who would decide the
fate and further expansion of the Roman
Empire
[Music]
udemon Arabia in ancient Yemen had been
the main Harbor of the mysterious
serbians
but now the harbor buildings were
engulfed in flames sending High Columns
of acrid smoke ascending into the sky
for you Damon Arabia had been the victim
of a Roman raid designed to test the
logistics and feasibility of a maritime
campaign route that could reach outer
Arabia
it was the Prelude to war
planned as a precursor to a larger
invasion of Southern Arabia led by the
Roman Commander Alias Galos the attack
was ordered by Augustus the successor to
Julius Caesar and the first true emperor
of Rome
but what great prize or knowledge had
brought Roman Conquest to this distant
region the answer could be found in the
acrid stench that was streaming from the
harbor and rising up into the darkening
sky like some perverse sacrifice to the
gods of War
incense
Arabian incense was sacred to many
cultures whether you're Roman Greek Jew
or Persian when the pungent smoke
released from burning desiccated tree
saps ascended Skyward it carried holy
fragrances towards the heavens indeed
incense was a much more appealing
offering to the many gods than the odor
of animal sacrifice
but it was not easy to obtain
Arabia was a remote land of extreme
deserts and the stunted trees that
produced this serp grew only on its
Southern coasts
The Cliffs and promontories of this
Seaboard were difficult to approach from
the coast and the region was seldom
entered by Outsiders and so the hardened
drops of sap produced by lacerating the
wiry incense trees was sent Inland
through desert trails to reach distant
trade stations near the Mediterranean or
the Persian Gulf these incense Trails
crossed A Thousand Miles through
restricted Caravan routes where Arabian
Merchants carried their precious loads
on heavily burdened camel teams incense
was so valuable that even small pouches
of this alluring substance could only be
purchased using multiple pouches of gold
and silver coins
early accounts of the biblical King
Solomon describe how he received an
incense Caravan from the Queen of Sheba
and sheba came to Jerusalem with a very
great Caravan with camels that bore
incense and very much gold and precious
stones and when she was come to Solomon
she communed with him concerning all
that was in her heart
indeed in 332 BC Alexander the Great
acquired vast stalks of Arabian incense
when he captured the Phoenician city of
tire on the Syrian Seaboard a decade
later with his Persian conquests
complete Alexander had planned to seize
Southern Arabia by launching a fleet
from the Persian Gulf but his sudden
unexplained death in Babylon had ended
the invasion plans
three centuries would pass before
another great ruler would attempt the
conquest
and so it was 25 BC when the Emperor
Augustus planned to surpass Alexander
and add Arabia to the Roman domains
although this was an economic decision
as much as anything else
five years earlier when Egypt became an
imperial Province there had been a boom
in consumer spending across the Empire
when vast wealth was released from the
ptolemaic Royal treasuries to be awarded
to Roman citizens
Augustus understood the large quantities
of Roman gold and silver were passing
into the hands of Arab Merchants through
the incense traffic and trade this was
an outpouring of finite Imperial bullion
to acquire a renewable resource why then
shouldn't the Romans possess this region
and control the substance that was most
sacred to their gods strabo reports
a report had prevailed from Early times
that the Arabians had become very
wealthy from Trading aromatics and
valuable gemstones for gold and silver
but they never exchanged any part of
this accumulated wealth without ciders
Augustus therefore expected to deal with
wealthy allies or Master wealthy enemies
with this Conquest the Romans could even
dream about flanking the Rival parthian
Empire which dominated Iran and
controlled the Persian Gulf
and so
War in preparation the Roman governor of
Egypt ileus gallus was given command of
ten thousand soldiers at first the
Romans assumed that a seaborne campaign
conducted through the Red Sea would
provide the best route to reach the
Serbian Kingdom but reports were not
favorable the Red Sea coasts of Arabia
were Barren and largely inaccessible due
to strong tidal currents and dangerous
Uncharted reefs
it was therefore decided that the Roman
conquest of Arabia would be a full-scale
landwood Invasion through the Hostile
desert along the mysterious Caravan
routes
gallus crossed from Egypt into the
neighboring Kingdom of nabatia in
Northwest Arabia this territory was
still subject to the Empire and the
Roman army was received and resupplied
at the Oasis City of Petra enabling
Judea King Herod the Great sent 500
desitiquipped soldiers to assist the
Romans on their campaign led by
nabataean military guides the
legionaries marched past the giant rock
cut edifices that flanked the main
routes into Petra they must have
marveled at the salmon-colored cliffs
and the massive ornate buildings carved
onto these steep rock facades this was
only the outer Frontier of the lucrative
incense trails that extended vast
distances across the shifting Sands
surely there were greater wonders in the
as yet unexplored desert itself
the campaign Force successfully captured
a series of Oasis towns and outposts
which became a network for future Roman
travel but their progress was extremely
slow and after six months on the
outbound operations the supplies
dwindled a suspicion began to form in
the minds of some soldiers crossing the
forbidding terrain what if the
nabataeans had contrived some treachery
against the Romans to preserve their own
stake in the lucrative incense trade
but finally the Romans did reach the
Sabian Kingdom on the southern Edge Of
Arabia Rocky Hills Rose into view and
Groves of palm trees and cultivated
Fields became more frequent great dams
had been constructed to collect streams
from the coastal Highlands to irrigate
this desert periphery crops provided
sustenance for cluttered mud brick
cities encircled by tall walls on the
plains before the settlements ranks of
disciplined legionaries formed up to
engage poorly equipped mob-like
Defenders with little experience in
professional Warfare as to be an army
fled to their cities and prepared to
defend their walled capital
my rib
the legions had almost reached their
objective
but as the siege of Mara began
mysterious Affliction spread throughout
the troops
their limbs weakened and their teeth
began to loosen in their mouths maybe
they were offending the gods by seeking
to possess the incense
had the stricken Roman army fallen from
Divine favor
the effects were real and the
psychological impact dramatic
Roman Medics could not diagnose the true
cause of this unknown ailment and they
urged gallus to withdraw before the
entire Army succumbed perhaps the
condition was scurvy caused by a lack of
vitamin C in the campaign diet the
nabataean supply lines must have been at
their maximum capacity and the serbians
would have stripped all food resources
from the land as they retreated within
their walled cities
and so finally the increasingly
diminished and demoralized Roman army
began a desperate Retreat North to
nabatian territory strabo reports
gallus was informed by his captives that
he was only two days journey from the
country that produces aromatics but he
had used up six months on his outbound
marches because of bad guidance
Gallows reached Petra in 60 days but
many soldiers had died on the journey
due to hardships disease and
insufficient supplies
gallus possibly went on to report that
something in the water of Southern
Arabia was harmful to people from
Mediterranean climates and so even
though Arabia had been invaded and
explored Augustus concluded that it
could never be permanently conquered or
added to the Roman domains
this route to India was closed
[Music]
in 52 A.D a group of distinguished Royal
envoys from a remote Kingdom were
ushered into the audience Hall of the
Roman Emperor Claudius
these astonishing strangers with their
dark complexions were from the far south
they were the mysterious counter-landers
who lived beneath another sky and
witnessed the influence of different
Stars
Clinique records the envoys Marvel that
the new aspect of the heavens visible in
our country they observed the stars that
formed the Great Bear the little bear
and the Pleiades they told us that in
their own country even the moon only
appears above the Horizon from the 8th
to the 18th day of the month they said
that canapus a large and Brilliant star
lights their Sky by night
but what surprised the most was that
their Shadows fell towards our sky and
not towards theirs also the sun rose on
the left hand of the Observer and set
upon the right
these counter Landers came from an
island on the outer edge of India known
to Greek and Roman Merchants as
temperbane ancient Sri Lanka this was
the most distant diplomatic contact the
Roman Empire had ever received
seems that attacks collecting Roman
businessman had made contact with this
semi-legendry region the result was this
remarkable event the arrival of distant
envoys seeking opportunities for
political friendship and Commercial
Alliance in Rome
but this wasn't the first time the
Indian subcontinent had come into
contact with the Greco-Roman world
half a millennium earlier in 518 BC the
first Greeks to explore India had
arrived as part of the Persian army
commanded by the achaemonite king Darius
the Great
Herodotus reports
Darius discovered the greatest part of
Asia he observed how crocodiles could be
seen in the Indus River just like the
Nile wishing to know how it connected to
the Sea he sent a team of trustworthy
men including psylax of coriander to
sail down the river they sailed Westward
and after a voyage of 30 months they
reached a place in Egypt once the voyage
was completed Darius conquered the Indus
and the Persians made use of the sea in
those regions
two centuries later Alexander the Great
that his greco-acidonian armies towards
India on his own mission of conquest and
exploration
in the high mountain passes leading to
the Hindu Kush his home six soldiers
thought they detected signs of their own
Gods and heroes who traveled to this
remote region
could the wild vines and creepers
growing their nicer be evidence that
Backus the Greek god of revelry and wine
had passed by this ancient city
and perhaps the mountain people who
fought with clubs and wore animal skins
were followers of Hercules
Alexander launched his Fleet on the
Indus River to support his army on its
progress South towards the ocean that
encircled the whole world
Marvels were seen on the coast including
giant Vivid colored clams with folded
bivalve shells out at Sea the humps of
blue whales Rose and fell on the ocean
foam suggesting the presence of great
leviathans in the unknown depths
large whales live in the outer ocean and
there are fishes much larger than those
that exist in our Inland Sea
nayakus reports that when they departed
at Daybreak they saw water being blown
upwards from the sea as if it was being
propelled by the force of a water spout
crew were astonished and asked the
pilots of the fleet what might be
causing this disturbance they replied
that creatures roving about the ocean
will spout up water to a great height
the sailors were so startled by this
site that the oars fell from their hands
but nayakus encouraged and cheered them
onwards as he sailed past the galleys he
signaled to them to turn their bows
towards the whales as if to give battle
then raising their war cry they Advanced
with rapid Strokes of the oars with this
great sound the sailors regained their
courage then as they neared the monsters
they shouted with all their effort
Bugles blared and the oars pounded the
water the whales now visible at the
bowels of the ships were terrified and
dived Into the Depths
under the command of Alexander Greek
military fleets could have explored the
outer limits of the Indian Ocean but
this was not to be plans were made for
the conquest of Southern Arabia but when
Alexander died mysteriously in Babylonia
his empire was divided between generals
who claimed Royal titles and established
Regional dynasties
the possibility of trade and
communication with far-off India was
lost for nearly two centuries
and so it wasn't until 118 BC in one of
the kingdoms founded by Alexander's
generals ptolemaic Egypt that contact
between West and East was once again
made the house of Ptolemy had
established ports and harbors on the Red
Sea Coast and had sent Greek hunting
parties South by ship to capture live
African elephants this created a
military network with an infrastructure
through the Eastern desert to Ports
furnished for distant voyages
by chance one of these Royal ships
encountered a strange wreck with a lone
survivor clinging to its wooden frame
strabo explains
according to the account a certain
Indian was brought to the King by the
patrol ships that sailed the gulf next
to Arabia they said they had found him
alone and half dead on a stranded ship
the king placed the Indian under the
charge of Greek instructors so that he
could learn our language when he had
learned Greek he explained that he had
been on a voyage from India his ship had
lost its course due to strange Miss
chance and only after all his companions
had died from starvation he had safely
reached Egypt
when his story was doubted he promised
to act as a guide on the journey to
India a group of men were selected by
the king and eudoxus became a member of
this group
eudoxus was a man inclined to search out
and explore the peculiarities of new
regions and he was well informed about
nature
departing on his first voyage in 118 BC
eudoxus reached the Indus kingdoms to
return with a rich cargo of spices
pearls and precious stones
From This Moment onwards the Realms of
India were Within Reach of the boldest
Mediterranean Merchants who made voyages
across the distant ocean
but this Commerce did not reach its full
potential for almost a century until
Rome annexed Egypt and Augustus was
proclaimed the first emperor
at the beginning of the First Century
A.D Roman ships did not sail beyond the
west coast of India the Deep hold
Merchant vessels were too large and
cumbersome to safely navigate the line
of reefs swells and shallows that
extended from India to Sri Lanka and so
this island known to the Romans as
taprabane was therefore unexplored
territory Roman seafarers even feared
that taperbane might be the outer edge
of some vast Southern continent the
antipodes as suggested by Pythagorean
theory vast land masses or separate
other worlds occupying the southern
hemisphere
these speculations were finally
challenged in ad52 during the reign of
Claudius with the arrival of the counter
Landers
Pliny relays the story of why the
counter Lander envoys was sent to Rome
starting with another Roman trade vessel
ship blown off course
taprabane also known as the territory of
the counter Landers was long considered
to be another world that is until anayas
pakamus had obtained a contract from the
state treasury to collect red sea taxes
one of his Freeman agents was sailing
around Arabia when he was carried by
gale force winds from the north and
swept beyond the coast of carmania after
a fortnight they made the harbor of
hippuri in tapperabane
the unfamiliar looking lost Roman tax
collector had been taken to the sin of
these King and his extraordinary cargo
inspected by Royal agents the strange
vessel and its prized cargo seemed
astonishing the ship was carrying a
large Consignment of high-value imperial
gold and silver coinage that had been
destined for the southern Arabian
incense markets
the sinalese king and his Royal
ministers carefully examined the foreign
coins they scrutinized the metallic
faces of distant rulers and marveled at
the fine dice struck portraits of
Augustus Tiberius Caligula and Claudius
the reverse of these coins depicted the
outlines of strange buildings foreign
temples and the images of unknown gods
within six months the Roman traveler had
learned the local language and could
converse with his hosts could the
accounts he told them of his home in a
great western civilization possibly be
true
Pliny records how the sinalis king sent
envoys to investigate the Roman Empire
and introduce the anuradipura realm as a
political Ally and Commercial associate
indeed one of the final notable acts of
the emperor Claudius was to receive and
acknowledge these exotic ambassadors
this meant that during his time as
Emperor Claudius had both occupied
Britain and established diplomatic
contacts with Sri Lanka two distant
Islands on opposite edges of the Earth
after this remarkable contact Roman
ships began making direct ocean
Crossings to Sri Lanka and the
anuradipura kingdom
Roman captains developed faster voyages
across the ocean and by sailing around
Sri Lanka they extended their Ventures
to trade ports in East India the Ganges
and Burma
a series of ambitious unnamed Merchants
each prepared to undertake longer and
riskier voyages added to the range and
scope of Roman trade contacts across the
vast Eastern ocean
these commercial explorers headed ever
further east tracking rumors and distant
contacts towards the mysterious Sarahs
the silk people at the edge of the known
world
and so the Romans kept pushing the
boundaries
of their knowledge
[Music]
centurions from the praetorian guard had
trekked for weeks through the canyon
deserts of Nubia south of Egypt
now finally they were entering the Royal
audience Hall of the king of muroi the
leading African Kingdom in these distant
lands
these Roman officers caked with the
debris and dust of long-distance travel
a journeyed more than 900 miles from the
frontiers of Egypt
the Empire had already conquered and
controlled the Mediterranean Coastline
of North Africa that faced southern
Europe but this narrow strip was only a
fraction of the vast African continent
in land from the fertile coastal zones
Africa became increasingly arid as it
merged into desert wastelands the Sahara
Desert covering North Africa with a belt
of barren land almost 3 000 miles wide
stretching from the Red Sea to the
Atlantic Ocean
extending nearly a thousand miles from
north to south it had an expanse larger
than the land mass of the entire Roman
Empire
in the ancient past Berber Caravans with
knowledge of wells and Oasis stations
were able to cross this brutal landscape
with the extreme conditions confined the
Romans to the Seaboard Fringe of North
Africa though there was another route to
Cross this desert expands
after the Romans conquered Egypt they
had gained control over the northern
part of the Nile River but they were
reluctant to extend their rules South
into the barren wastes
now finally they were entering the Royal
audience Hall of the king of merui the
leading African Kingdom in these distant
lands
this Zone was under the control of an
African kingdom known as merowie or
ancient Kush
the earliest Greek Legends recalled an
error when the people of kush conquered
Egypt and African pharaohs with
distinctive dark complexions commanded a
unified nilotic Kingdom
the 25th Dynasty that it ruled Egypt
during the 8th Century BC was
contemporary with the famous Greek
author Homer who composed The Iliad and
the Odyssey
Homer had recited the legend of memnon
the champion king of kush who led an
African Army North to support the
Trojans in their war against the Greeks
memnon was a warrior of great skill and
Valor but he was slain in epic combat
with the Supreme Greek hero Achilles
the Romans regarded the Trojans as their
legendary ancestors
so how should they view merui surely as
potential allies
based on Greek knowledge of Africa the
Romans believed that the continent
terminated just south of the vast Sahara
Desert early accounts had confirmed that
these distant territories contained Bush
savannas and semi-forested regions these
were the homelands of Africans known
collectively as Ethiopians Pythagorean
theory also suggested that nature had
created Symmetry and all-natural
phenomena had an equivalent opposite
Africa therefore had similar Dimensions
to Europe and the Nile was expected to
follow an East-West Direction equivalent
to the Danube River
but where was its origin
determined to learn the truth of the
Great River the Emperor Augustus sent a
Roman army into the central Sahara led
by a commander named Cornelius balbus
and in 20 BC balbus crossed the inner
desert headed towards the fezan region
of Southern Libya
he conducted a rapid campaign matching
600 miles south from Reggio tropolitania
on a course through the open desert that
took at least 24 days to accomplish
the Romans captured the main Oasis
centers of garamantia but their
Engineers were utterly perplexed by the
outflow of endless fresh water the
garamantes had access to they reasoned
that perhaps the garamantes had tapped
into a vast underground river did the
Nile actually flow beneath the desert
in reality the garamantes were accessing
prehistoric aquifers
these underground water sources were the
residue of vast Upland lakes that had
seeped below the Earth in earlier
Millennia the Romans who surveyed this
arid terrain did not understand the true
age of the Earth nor could they begin to
Fathom the extraordinary alterations
caused by changes in climate thus the
underground river Theory provided a
credible explanation for hidden water
sources
Beyond this all balbus discovered was
Desert
though he did celebrate a Triumph in
Rome the Empire withdrew from garamantic
territory it seems that Augustus and his
successors were prepared to leave the
mystery of the Nile and its emergence
unanswered
but this wasn't the case for long
when the Romans seized direct control
over the subject Kingdom of Mauritania
in 1840 new discoveries were made
ancient Mauritania was situated on the
Mediterranean Seaboard of northwest
Africa stretching from Algeria to
Morocco
sudden Roman annexation provoked an
uprising on the desert Frontiers
two legionary armies were redeployed to
suppress the Rebellion one of the
commanders a man named Gaius swetonius
or Linus
and Gaius was an ambitious man
in 1841 Paul Linus marched his army
South towards the atlas mountains that
formed the furthest limits of the
Kingdom he laid his legionaries through
sweltering forests on the edge of
Morocco and encountered strange and
startling animals including tarantulas
scorpions and bizarre monkeys
on the third Paul Linus ascended and
crossed the atlas range passing beneath
African Peaks still covered with snow
even during The Heat Of Summer from
these high Vistas paulinus surveyed the
landscape beyond the mountains and saw
the glint of a river flowing on the Arid
desert Plains below
he let his troops down into the
scorching black sand desert but when
they reached the distant River they
discovered it to be nothing but a weak
trickle Meandering through Barren lands
Holiness abandoned his expedition and so
this was the furthest territory that the
Romans had explored but there was still
no sign of the Western Nile
[Music]
Pliny the Elder hinted at the true
purpose of the mission an exploring
party was recently sent by the emperor
Nero it seems that among his other Wars
he's actually contemplating an attack on
Ethiopia in Africa
and so in ad61 the praetorians left
Roman territory in Egypt and headed
south to seek an audience with the king
of marawi posing as diplomats and
explorers the Roman party took careful
note of distances and resources on an
estimated
945-mile Trek from scyene to the Royal
capital of merway
ancient Egyptian texts recorded about 25
Urban centers along the Nubian Nile
however on their Trek South the Romans
discovered that most of these
settlements had been abandoned centuries
earlier praetorians following the course
of the Nile examined dry crumbling ruins
of outposts and temples built by past
civilizations of immense Antiquity based
on these reports Pliny argued it was not
Rome that made this country a desert
this region was worn out by alternate
periods of dominance and subjection in a
series of wars with Egypt
having been a famous and powerful
country even down to the time of the
Trojan Wars
this Nubian desert ended near the
outskirts of merway here the land
finally became fertile and forested
Pliny records Greener herbage appears
near the city and stretches a forest
come into view where the tracks of
rhinos and elephants can be seen
on arrival at marrowee the trail weary
praetorians declared their status as
envoys and asked for an audience with
the ruler of the city
they were eventually taken to the Royal
audience chamber
in the Gloom of the temple-like palace
Hall towering stone statues loomed from
between ornamental pillars tall reliefs
displayed images of strange lion-headed
Gods but also disturbing scenes of past
conflicts
a century earlier morotic armies had
stormed the Frontier City of cyan in
southern Egypt taking some Roman
prisoners and decapitating Bronze
Statues of the Emperor Augustus some
reliefs in merui depicted Roman soldiers
made to kneel in submission it was a
reminder that Rome was not always
triumphant on the edges of its Empire
the leading Tribune of the praetorians
stepped forward to request a favor from
the African king a message from the
golden Emperor Nero the ruler of Mighty
Army in Imperial Rome
Venero wanted something from inner
Africa
the praetorians waited while the king
considered his response the acrid scent
of Somali incense filled the audience
Hall drifting through shafts of
brilliant sunlight and penetrating
through elevated openings near the
ceiling on familiar faces with uniquely
dark complexions scrutinized the new
Roman arrivals exhausted by their
travels through strange and arid lands
the praetorians must have struggled to
maintain their composure Their Fear and
unease was justified merui was not a
subject nation and Rome had no Dominion
here
but the king of merui offered them
support
Seneca confirms the king supplied them
with assistance and gave them letters of
introduction to the neighboring rulers
then they set out on their long journey
into the center of Africa
but the course of the Nile did not
extend Westward as most Roman
authorities had supposed the praetorians
instead found themselves pushing deeper
into Africa following the White Nile
South 600 miles until they reached a
seemingly impossible barrier
the sud
is a primordial wetland in southern
Sudan filled with ferns fields of
Papyrus Reeds and thick mats of rotting
vegetation in the rainy season it
becomes a vast humid swamp teeming with
mosquitoes and other insects those who
entered this region had to endure
sweltering heat the fear of disease and
the threat of starvation
the sud was too deep to be safely
crossed on foot yet the water was too
shallow to be explored any further by
boat it was also vast it included almost
300 miles of swollen Wetland the heavy
clay soils retained and expanded the
outflow of semi-stagnant water far
beyond the vision of any explorers
the water teamed with strange sharp
finned fish and the Explorers must have
had to keep Keen watch for the outlines
of crocodiles amongst the drifting
debris the dense hulking shapes of
hippopotami would watch
half-submerged snorting in sputtering
bursts as The Travelers passed by they
were to be avoided in case these
monstrous animals decided to charge Gore
or batter crew and craft
praetorians must have realized that
these beasts were large and powerful
enough to overturn and smash their small
vessels what use could their swords and
javelins be and all the while the
persistent Sun blazed down upon this
wretched landscape
these sluggish pools teamed with clouds
of incessant mosquitoes and even at
microscopic level the water was a living
poison
minuscule waterborne parasites would
have infected the bladder and kidneys
causing skin irritations stomach cramps
and diarrhea skin sores cuts and lesions
would not heal in this infected decaying
environment it must have seemed to the
despairing Romans that they had reached
the chaotic and primordial edge of
nature where Mata became indistinct and
creation was half formed
finally sodon and exhausted the
praetorians could go no further the
Tribune gazed out across the endless
shimmering Haze of swamp and gave the
order
turn back
on the return to Italy the Roman
explorers told Seneca we came to Great
swamps the borders of which even the
natives did not know we could not find
the limits of this place the river was
completely entangled with vegetable
growth and the waters were impassable by
foot because of the muddy overgrowth but
we saw two rocks from which an immense
quantity of water issued
perhaps they prudently suggested this
was one of the underground sources of
the Nile issuing forth like a fountain
to flood the land from the reports given
by the Explorers Roman cartographers
prepared a diagram that outlined the
major Invasion routes into sub-Saharan
Africa
Pliny describes this object as the
schematic plan of Ethiopia recently
presented to the emperor Nero
and so Nero set his plans into action an
imperial residence was prepared in the
Egyptian capital of Alexandria and
troops were sent to the city in
preparation for an imminent campaign
legion's extra tensis and V macadonica
were sent to Egypt to extend Roman rule
deep into Africa
but
it was not to be
there was an uprising against the Romans
in Judea at the same time as the legions
in northern Europe rebelled against the
emperor
eventually even the praetorians withdrew
their support and the Senate declared
Nero An Enemy of the State The Fugitive
Emperor fled the Imperial Palace and
took his own life rather than suffer the
pain and humiliation of a public
execution
the Romans would never find the true
source of the Nile and soon their
probing reach would change its focus and
turn northwards
[Music]
much of Northern Europe was covered in a
dense and ancient Woodland known to the
Romans as the hercinian forest
tall deciduous trees towered over the
thick leaf-matted forest floor creating
a gloomy canopy that hemmed in and
overshadowed anyone moving through this
vast and claustrophobic expanse
it was a disorientating Wilderness
utterly Savage and disconcerting for
Roman Travelers Savage wild animals
lived in these places and hostile
Germanic tribes folk could stalk or
Ambush those who trespassed through
their dark domains indeed scattered
somewhere in this silent Eerie forest
was the scene of an atrocity
Berg Massacre
butchered remains of three entire
Legions littered the forest floor their
corpses desecrated and displayed on
trees in strange Germanic Customs
presented as offerings to Savage hostile
gods
what could possibly temp to roam an
adventurers to Brave this Wilderness
the answer
was Amber resin
early Greek Theory suggested that ambo
was the congealed rays of the Sun as it
set into a frozen atmosphere of course
it had already been established that the
cold of Northern regions could turn
seawater into a solid substance and
condensed the air into an impenetrable
fog but over time this idea had changed
burning Amber chippings produced the
smell of pine sap and there was strange
and exotic insects scorpions beetles and
wasps embedded in the solidified
substance this would suggest that the
material was probably some sort of tree
resin however the process that
transformed sap to gem was unknown might
the Romans discover the mystery was
there a land of Perpetual daylight
concealed in the far north
and so as in Africa Nero's interest had
been peaked
another Envoy had returned to Rome
having undertaken a distant Mission far
beyond the frontiers of the empire for
the emperor he had followed trade routes
North beyond the Danube Frontiers
Crossing 600 miles of hostile and
unknown territory to acquire a valuable
prize a mysterious resource from the
Frozen oceans of the far north
baltic amber a fossilized tree resin
found in deep subsurface sediments on
the Baltic Coast it was the remains of a
vast coniferous forest from the eocene
epoch over 44 million years ago the
erosion of this strata by turbulent
North Sea storms and tidal flows cast
this Amber onto the shores where it was
gathered by ancient peoples Germanic
populations offered Amber to the ancient
britons and conveyed it Inland through
the rivers of Central Europe to reach
outposts of classical civilizations in
the Black Sea and the Mediterranean
centuries before the Roman era Amber
from the Baltic coasts of the North Sea
had reached the Greek world it was cut
ground and Polished into ornaments and
these bright translucent orbs had the
value of precious gemstones
a strange and intriguing material it was
used to Adorn Greek necklaces and
decorate the shields of carthaginian
soldiers
Greek myth had suggested that pieces of
Amber were the tears shed by the sisters
of faithon when they heard of his demise
they were The Offspring of Helios the
Sun God who had allowed his child faith
on a semi-divine youth to drive the sun
chariot
the boy had lost control of the speeding
vehicle and tumbled to his death
somewhere in the Frozen North
in Romans Syria Amber was prized for the
household craft of spinning Yarns it had
electrostatic properties and would draw
fibers and threads towards the spindle
ambo was therefore known as harpax or
the snatcher Pliny observed that when
Amber was warmed by rubbing it could
pick up dry leaves or straw and catch
the fine fringes of garments noting
these strange properties the Greeks had
called Amber elektrum or The Shining one
yet the peoples of Northern Europe had
remained distant and unknown to the
Romans until the outbreak of the symbric
war
in about 120 BC a sudden environmental
shift caused Great Flood Tides around
the Jutland peninsula destroying
farmlands herds and habitats faced with
starvation the Germanic peoples known as
the simbry and tutons began a mass
migration into Gaul merging with Celtic
warriors and moving with their families
they became an invasion Force as they
pushed South towards Roman Italy
and 101 BC after more than a decade of
conflict the Roman Legions finally
defeated and destroyed the last of these
Germanic Invaders but the distant
homelands of these people remained a
curious mystery but the Roman annexation
of Germania finally began in 16 BC when
the first Emperor Augustus placed his
adopted son Nero Claudius drusus in
command of the legions and tasked him
with a great campaign of conquest and
exploration
crossing the Rhine the armies led by
drewsus reached the elbe river which
flows into the North Sea near the
Jutland peninsula when drewsis died from
an injury on campaign Augustus appointed
his successor Tiberius as the
replacement commander who launched
several seaward operations as far as the
Jutland peninsula and secured greater
Germania for the Empire Augustus boasted
of these achievements in his memorial
statement
I restored the provinces of Gaul and
Spain and pacified Germany securing the
ocean from cadith to the mouth of the
river elb I commanded my ships to sail
the ocean from the mouth of the Rhine
East to the lands bordering the simbry
where no Roman had gone before either by
land or sea
but the Roman Advanced into Germania
interior would not be a lasting Conquest
in 89 the Germans staged a rebellion and
massacred three entire Legions in the
dark and wild dudiburg forest
the elderly Augustus suffered a severe
reaction when he heard this news never
fully recovering
and so drusus and Tiberius seemed to
have set the limits for Roman knowledge
and expansion on the Northern Fringe of
Europe
to many Romans it seemed as if they were
fighting against nature itself in their
efforts to conquer and pacify Germania
the emperor Tiberius continued the
conflict but in ad16 the Roman fleet was
caught in a severe storm while ferrying
a land Army from the M's River back to
the Rhine Frontier
the disaster was described by a Roman
poet named albino varnas pedo the work
itself was not survived but a passage
quoted by Seneca clearly expresses Roman
fears about the northern ocean hedo
wrote
they witnessed daylight but the sun is
left far behind they are long exiled
from the well-known limits of the world
they have dared to go into the Forbidden
bloom-filled territories at the edge of
creation to try and reach its father's
Shores
now they behold the ocean which has
monsters beneath its sluggish waves
on all sides as Savage sharks and dogs
of the sea crashing waves and wrathful
billowing winds seized their ships
Rising them high in the water and
swelling them with fear
as their Fleet is caught by Swift winds
they feel their ships impacting on a
Shoal the remorseless Fates will mangle
them or deliver them to the wild
creatures of the ocean
one man stands defiant on the high prow
he cries out the thoughts of his
imprisoned Soul where are we being taken
by the storm should we even be searching
for Nations who dwell Beyond another Sky
we are violating foreign seas and sacred
Waters with our oars why do we trouble
the untouched Dwelling Places of the
Gods
during the storm the great fleet was
smashed apart and dispersed with an
enormous loss of life in the aftermath
of the disaster Tiberius finally
abandoned Roman plans to recover the
region and greater Germania remained
permanently outside the empire
due to this decision Baltic territories
beyond the jotlin peninsula remained
poorly explored by Roman authorities in
his Natural History completed in ad75
Pliny the Elder still relies on the
accounts of pythius to describe the
territories Beyond Jutland
pythius says the German people called
the gutones inhabited the shores of an
estuary on the ocean called mentonomon
their territory extends 6000 stadia the
island does burn Amber's fuel were
traded with their neighbors
the catones are possible ancestors of
the Goths who centuries later would
invade the Roman Empire contributing to
its decline fragmentation and eventual
collapse
north south east and west had the Roman
Empire finally reached the ends of the
Earth
foreign
the Romans had finally broken through
they had completed a sudden and
Relentless March through the mountains
on the west flank of Britain finally
reaching the Uncharted West Coast they
now stood on the very shores of the
Irish sea within their sight lay the
island of Mona a sacred druidic Center
and Powerful base for Celtic opposition
to Rome
force was commanded by the governor
suretonius Paul Linus the same man who
would cross the high Atlas Mountains in
North Africa two decades earlier now he
found himself in the mountainous
landscape of Wales receiving the final
details of the coming attack against the
Celtic resistance he had summoned his
senior military staff to the campaign
tent to explain their orders and among
them was a young 20 year old Tribune
named nias Julius Agricola
The Druids and the leaders of the Celtic
resistance would consider themselves
invulnerable within their Island's
stronghold of Mona but Paul Linus had a
plan
under the orders of Paul Linus the
classes Britannica had constructed
special flat bottom landing craft the
fleet would convey the assembled Legions
across the narrow menai strait to
assault the sacred Island
but as the Romans prepared to disembark
on the shores of Mona a hideous sight
was revealed
for The Druids had prepared an army of
Celtic tribes a fanatical enemy was
invoking terrible curses on the incoming
legionaries black clad Priestess
carrying flaming torches ran between the
ranks of frenzied Warriors shrieking
like crows fearful paralysis grip the
Romans perhaps there were indeed Mystic
powers and evil entities on the fringes
of the known world
[Music]
for a long time the Greeks and Romans
had feared and respected the ancient
Celts people from classical
civilizations recognized common motifs
and images amongst the cattle raising
cultures of Northwest Europe indeed
early Greek myths of Hercules may have
been influenced by the Celtic gods as
they appeared on early artifacts or
religious items Luke of the long arm was
a radiant Celtic Warrior God who
encouraged cattle raids Master of the
spear and slingshot Adept at oratory and
unsurpassed in all the Artisan skills of
craftsmanship he was represented with
three heads symbolizing the three great
aspects of his supernatural character
the cooler head from ancient Island
depicts the deity with three separate
faces on a single Stone Cranium in early
Greek myths the 10th great Labor of
Hercules was to enter the distant
Atlantic and steal the red cattle of the
Monstrous giant Gary on garyon was a
triple-headed entity with a fearsome
Hound that guarded his Island Home in
the Far West
but perhaps the Romans were right to
fear Celtic rituals Julius Caesar
himself had heard reports that the
Continental Celts burned sacrificial
victims in giant wicker structures
whilst leading two Expeditions into
Southern Britain in 55 and 54 BC
suppressing tribes who had supported the
Gauls against Rome
the Celtic Islands had other strange
sights and wonders such as extraordinary
War horns known as karnics these tall
instruments were shaped like gaping
mouths of hideous creatures and some had
hinged tongues that clacked as the
Warriors advanced in a Celtic Army the
trumpet-like horns projected far above
the heads of the tallest Warriors so
that the Monstrous howling creatures
seemed to join and jostle for place in
the frenzied battle line
and so in preparation for combat with
these distant Horrors the emperor
Claudius brought his own monsters to
Britain when he invaded the island in
ad43
war elephants
the Celts venerated bristle-backed wild
boars as powerful Warrior totems so
massive elephants with their long tusks
and trumpeting raw were truly horrifying
claudius's victory in Britain was seen
as a triumph over the Great Northern
ocean itself
so etonius describes the ceremonies in
Rome where Among The Spoils of Victory
Claudius fixed a naval Crown next to the
Civic crown on the pediment of the
Palatine Palace this was a sign that he
had crossed over and conquered the ocean
suetonius Paul Linus the Roman general
who crossed the high Atlas Mountains
became the governor of Britannia in ad58
the small offshore province of Britain
was well established but most of the
island remained Beyond Roman control
orlinus was given the position by Nero
but he still maintained his own personal
motives and interests in particular he
was Keen to outdo the exploits of a
contemporary named corbillo who was
conducting a dangerous war against the
parthians in mountainous Armenia
compelled by this rivalry Holiness LED
his own military Expedition into unknown
hostile British territories
perhaps it was Nero who encouraged
renewed action on the Frontiers or maybe
paulinus was inspired by current events
indeed in the South praetorians were
exploring the Nile and inequitous that
embarked North to find the distant
source of Amber put Paul Linus not do
likewise
he could lead his Legions to the western
edge of Britain and look across the
Irish sea at the furthest unconquered
lands how could Nero with his
fascination with exploration and distant
lands possibly object
and so Paul Linus had marched his
Legions Westward tacitus reports now
Britain was under the command of
suetonius Paul Linus a man who vied with
kobalo in attaining military experience
and popular favor paulinus therefore
prepared to attack the island of Mona
which had a powerful population and was
a refuge for fugitives on the opposite
Shore stood the opposing army with a
dense array of well-armed Warriors
between their ranks dashed women with
their hair disheveled dressed in black
attire like the furies and waving
firebrands all around were The Druids
lifting their hands up to heaven and
pouring forth Dreadful incantations how
soldiers were terrified by this
unfamiliar sight and paused as if their
limbs were paralyzed they stood
motionless and exposed to wounds
thank you
eventually Paul Linus yelled the orders
advance in order
charge
the spell was broken and the ranks
advanced
it was soon over
the well-organized soldiers butchered
the enemy and burnt the sacred Groves
another enemy of Rome had been destroyed
the younger gricola participated in the
military actions learning the skills and
attitudes that would one day inform and
guide his own decisions in high office
but as the Romans dismantled the Celtic
shrines news suddenly reached paulinus
that the province of Britain was in
Revolt
on the East Coast the previously
submissive icini tribe had rebelled
their Queen Boudicca re-armed her people
and inflicted Devastation on the poorly
defended Roman communities paulinus led
a rushed and desperate March back across
the mountains to rescue The Province
though the outnumbered Romans were
victorious in battle the damage had been
done
entire populations were butchered or
flared as refugees as the new colonies
and cities were burnt were abandoned
Nero considered withdrawing the legions
permanently from Britain but for the
sake of honor the province was retained
nevertheless lessons were learned and
further expansion halted for more than a
decade writing in ad75 Pliny claims that
Britain had not been explored beyond the
Caledonian Forest ancient Scotland
and so in the far north at the crest of
the world what lay Beyond
and who would dare to make this journey
[Music]
during the political high point of the
Roman Empire two distant Travelers met
by chance at the sacred site of dolphy
in Central Greece
they began discussing the extent and
form of the world as revealed by ancient
texts and their own Explorations in
Faraway lands on the edge of the empire
an account of their conversation was
recorded by the Greek writer Plutarch
who says his brother lampreyas joined
the Travelers in their discussions
Delphi was considered to be the sacred
cultural center of Greece and the
midpoint of the entire ancient world it
was known as the omphalus or the navel
of the earth a myth described how Zeus
had simultaneously launched Two Eagles
from the opposite edges of the globe and
the birds met one another in the skies
directly above Delphi the Travelers were
Cleon brotus of Sparta and Demetrius of
Tarsus and like the eagles of Zeus each
should returned from opposite edges of
the known world
Cleon brotus was a wealthy traveler from
the ancient territory of Sparta in
southern Greece he had journeyed for
knowledge and experience across the
entire ocean to India Plutarch writes
the journeys by Cleon brotos were not
for business he was fond of seeing
things and of acquiring knowledge he had
sufficient wealth and felt that it was
not any great advantage to have more
than enough so he spent his leisure time
involved in traveling and inquiry
but Demetrius
was different
he had been on a very different Mission
he was a grammarian a language expert
who had been recruited as a military
agent and had been on an imperial
assignment to the mysterious Celtic
islands of the northwest coast of
Britain
plutoc rights
Demetrius said that there were many
isolated Islands positioned near Britain
these islands had few or no inhabitants
and some bought the names of divinities
or Heroes
he himself by the emperor's order had
made a voyage for inquiry and
observation to the nearest of these
lands
Agricola the governor of Great Britain
had requested Greek intellectuals for
some great adventure in the North
Atlantic
Demetrius had answered this call in his
role as an imperial agent he had been
sent to isolated islands off the coast
of ancient Britain probably traveling
aboard a Roman War Galley one of many
that had been sent to explore and map a
series of islands and coastlines located
to the west of Britain and the north of
Ireland
the sudden approach of an Atlantic storm
drove the ship and its crew to seek
shelter ashore the Roman explorers were
forced to take refuge on some strange
Island for several days intrigued by
this edge of the world territory
Demetrius managed to communicate with
the inhabitants in their own dialect and
was told they were trespassing on a holy
Island
somewhere nearby was the resting place
of a dormant God the Demetrius
identified as Kronos
the Greek god Chronos was the primordial
being overthrown by Zeus Demetrius would
have also heard stories about the vast
ceremonial mounds of prehistoric peoples
who lived thousands of years before the
Celts and mysterious Stone circles
constructed by Neolithic populations
Roman galleys charting the North Coast
of Ireland who have already seen the
giant paved Causeway extending from the
rugged Coast into the depths of the sea
this undersea Causeway rose again on a
dark Island where a vast multi-columbed
cave emitted strange acoustic thrummings
this unique natural feature on the
island of staffer is known in modern
times as fingals cave
the close-fitting hexagonal stones of
the Giant's Causeway and fingals Cave
must have been viewed as the work of
deities or great Heroes it was clear
that the Roman fleet was trespassing on
the outer world of the Gods
and other questions had to be solved if
the Romans hoped to master this new
Northern environment
was Britain an island of unparalleled
size or simply the outer reaches of some
great northern counter land that
extended deep into the Hostile Arctic
Zone did this land mass have a terminus
even halfway across the world Britain
was famous for its mysterious size in
1866 the Jewish King Herod Agrippa had
made a speech to his people on the eve
of a failed Revolt Josephus reports
do not depend upon the walls of
Jerusalem the Romans have sought another
habitable Earth beyond the ocean they
have landed armies on British Islands
which were never known before consider
what a barrier the britons had they were
encircled by the ocean and yet the
Romans sailed across and subdued them
and the britons inhabit a land mass that
may not be smaller than this entire
inhabited Earth
and so in ad77 all the orders of the
emperor vespasion the newly appointed
Governor nayas Julius Agricola was
instructed to find and secure these
Frontiers wherever they might turn out
to be
[Music]
Agricola LED his Roman forces to the
edge of the Highlands and began
establishing the Firth Clyde Frontier
this was a 40-mile wide defensive
network of forts and embankments that
would form a permanent to Northern limit
to the British province
now a new conquest could begin so that
freedom would be removed from sight and
the caledonians would be entirely
isolated
and in ad-80 the Romans prepared their
Fleet for the conquest and annexation of
Ireland the final great Refuge of the
Celtic peoples this was to be the
emperor's final conquest and would
complete their exploration of the
distant West
tacitus reports in soil and climate in
the disposition and lifestyle of its
population Ireland differs little from
Britain the roots of approach and
harbors are better known to us through
Commerce and Merchants it would unite
the powerful parts of the Empire with
great mutual benefits
but unforeseen events coincided to Halt
the Roman invasion
[Music]
in 1881 the emperor Titus the eldest son
of vespasion suddenly died after only a
year in office he was succeeded by his
younger brother dimitian who had
different plans for Empire
and at almost the same time a remarkable
account was circulating it was the story
of a voyage
a newly recorded cohort of Germanic
auxiliaries had mutinied while stationed
on the west coast of Britain they had
murdered their commanding officers and
seized three War galleys to embark on
their escape their aim was to search for
some sea route first North then Eastward
back to their homelands beyond the Rhine
however the emaciated survivors had
reached Northern Germany on a single
remaining ship and they had been swiftly
recaptured and returned to Roman
Authorities on the Rhine Frontier the
survivors had told a remarkable story of
great daring and hardships ferocious
storms sea raids and cannibalism they
was a living proof that some sort of sea
route existed around the northern coasts
of Britain
Britain was confirmed to be an island
with its furthest limits just beyond the
contested Highland Zone
and by coincidence rumors now reached a
brickella of a major Uprising in the
islands in response Agricola cooled off
the Irish campaign and turned his full
military force northward against this
encroaching force of Highland Celts the
Roman Fleet joined with the land forces
to pursue the enemy into hostile
territory entering locks and deep ocean
inlets on the western coast of Scotland
tacitus reports
nowhere does the sea hold wider
influence over land the tidal currents
flows this way and that for the sea does
not merely ebb and flow along the coast
but it penetrates and winds its way deep
Inland placing itself amidst The Ridges
and mountains and forming its own domain
for the first time the fleet was
employed as an integral part of the land
Army and ships accompanied this campaign
the imposing facade of war was pushed
forward both by sea and land often Roman
infantry Cavalry and Marines shared the
same encampment cheerfully taking the
same meals they would evaluate battles
on land with victories on the ocean
two years of difficult campaigning
followed before the Romans were able to
inflict a serious defeat on their
elusive enemy late in the summer of ad83
Agricola LED his Legions deep into the
Highland Wilderness to attack a major
Gathering of Caledonian Warriors at a
site called mons gropius with this
Victory Agricola could claim that
Caledonia was finally subdued and so he
marched North with the legions to find
The Bleak limits of the land
and his orders the fleet based in the
Clyde Estuary conducted its Voyage of
exploration northward to confirm the
outer limits of the British landmass by
sea
and there as winter was approaching they
observed another island in the far north
Beyond Britain
surely the land encountered Beyond these
Shores must be the semi-mythical Thule
tacitus reports there is a vast
irregular tract of land stretching out
from the furthermost shore of Caledonia
and tapering to a kind of wedge this was
the first time that a Roman Fleet had
circumnavigated this coast and crossed
the remotest sea they confirmed that
Britain was indeed an island although
they cited thul no Landing was made
since no orders for this purpose had
been issued and winter was approaching
in the next campaign season the Romans
might have followed this chain of outer
Islands northwards towards Iceland and
the edge of the Arctic Circle
but Agricola never undertook this
venture
he was recalled from Britain and the
fleet never re-entered these remote Seas
further expansion had become impractical
when the emperor dimitian recalled
essential troops from Britain
urgently needing to defend the
threatened Danube Frontier and protect
long-established Imperial possessions
Rome was on the defensive and it was the
embattled legions who now watched the
Frontiers with fear and apprehension
the captured territories in Caledonia
were abandoned and Ireland was never
added to the Empire
standing on a wet Promontory above the
Roman Fleet after the battle of mons
gropius nyas eulius Agricola had indeed
stood at the maritime edge of the
habitable world and it would remain that
way
for centuries afterwards
it is the second Century A.D Roman
civilization has reached its greatest
achievements
Alexandria the capital of Egypt stands
in the center of a vast World system
that connects the most distant regions
through vibrant commercial networks
hundreds of ships deliver thousands of
tons of Egyptian grain to Rome
but Alexandria also looks Eastward and
its Merchants could reach Southern India
in just 70 days the emperor trajan has
restored an ancient Canal linking the
Nile to the Suez Gulf this allows
travelers to avoid the hardships of the
Eastern desert on their Journeys to the
Red Sea ports Italy and India are
connected by trade through the great
Metropolis of Alexandria
so in The Great Library of Alexandria
Claudius Ptolemy is redrawing and
expanding the world map devised by his
predecessor marinos of tire
Roman political and economic power has
greatly expanded classical geography and
its Merchants repeatedly pass what used
to be the boundaries of the known world
unfortunately he has miscalculated the
size of the Earth reducing it to about
72 percent of actual size his landmass
measurements are too large on this
reduced globe and Northern Britain
extends too far into the Arctic Zone
Ptolemy therefore adjusts Caledonia by
making the northern part of Britain Bend
West East this is a minor change to a
territory that was no longer part of the
Empire but one consequence was that
Shetland is pushed Eastward towards
Scandinavia
but what about Thor
Ptolemy carefully reviews the map data
collected by Agricola we all accounts
Thule should be north of Britain so he
therefore plots the coordinates of
Shetland on his world map and labels
this land mass
Thule
the Romans had finally found and mapped
their Thule and the credit went to
Agricola
[Music]
advances in geographical knowledge were
also occurring on the Eastern edges of
the Known World a Motrin sailor named
alexandros wrote a new periplus that
outlined Roman voyages across the
eastern Indian Ocean Roman Merchant
ships now reached distant kingdoms such
as Burma and by following Indian sailing
routes around the Malay Peninsula they
arrived at the previously remote islands
of Sumatra Java and Borneo
Roman's saving records suggest that
beasts like satirs inhabited these lands
these could be orangutans the Romans
called this distant sea the Bay of Sinai
because some unknown route to LED North
to the outer territories of Han China
the furthest location on these distant
voyages was a mysterious trade Outpost
known as categora Ptolemy records
marinos does not provide a distance in
Star days for the sale from the golden
Peninsula to katagara however he does
record that alexandros had written that
the land from there curves South those
who sail along it reach the city of
zabai in 20 days and after sailing from
zabai Northeast for a few days they
reached katagara
perhaps categora was an eastern city
somewhere on the coast of Vietnam it
could have been visited by Chinese
Merchants from the nearby Han Empire
which the Romans knew as Sinai
but Roman Merchants were also extending
classical knowledge as they traveled
eastwards along the more direct
land-based silk routes to China
in about 80 100 Merchants were sent by
an influential Roman businessman named
Mayas titianus they were granted Passage
through the Rival parthian Empire which
occupied Iran trekking through bactria
ancient Afghanistan on trade routes
across the powerful kushan Empire their
destination was a trade Outpost close to
the distant pamir mountains known to
Merchants as the Stone Tower
here Caravans coming from Indian and
Iranian territories met with tarim
merchants and step Traders bullion and
other rare substances were exchanged at
the stone tower for precious Chinese
silk
the Roman Merchants who reached the
stone tower in ad100 seized the
opportunity to travel onwards into the
homelands of the mysterious Ceres the
ancient silk people Ptolemy records
the route from the stone tower to the
Saras is subject to extreme weather so
there must have been numerous pauses on
the journey the route only became known
through the opportunities for Commerce
marinos records that Juan Mayes also
known as titianus a Macedonian and
emergent by Family profession recorded
the distance Mayors did not travel the
route himself but sent agents to the
Ceres
and so tolomi used the distances
provided by Mayors to estimate the vast
size of Eastern Asia and having settled
upon the dimensions of the land of the
series he turned his gaze
southwards
[Music]
by this era Roman Merchants agents and
explorers had ventured further into
Africa too in pursuit of profit or on
special Imperial assignments Ptolemy
consulted accounts of Roman trading
voyages to a distant African trading
station called Raptor
Raptor was on the coast of Tanzania near
to the distant and mysterious island of
Madagascar voyages along these coasts
included sailings through the night
along Shores where the coast Rose
steeply upward to form desolate Cliffs
Ptolemy writes marinus records that the
sailing between the aromatic Promontory
and Raptor was undertaken by a certain
diogenese he was returning from India a
second time when he was driven south
from the Promontory by a strong Northern
wind he sailed South with Africa on his
right for 25 days till he reached a
position near the Lakes from which the
Nile flows
in the 8080s the emperor domitian sent
an Explorer team across the central
Sahara they crossed through garamatic
territory to enter the bush savannas in
the land beyond the Explorers entered
inner Africa and captured a rare
Savannah Rhino for display in Rome
Ptolemy describes how Julius maternus
spent four months on the outward journey
to this enigmatic land
Julius maternus traveled from leptus
Magna to garamantia and accompanied its
King on an expedition to the Ethiopians
after marching South for four months
they reached agassimba in the Ethiopian
country where the rhinoceros congregate
the captive African rhino was
transported a thousand miles across
Savannah and desert before being placed
on a ship Bound for Rome there in the
newly built Colosseum dimitian's Rhino
thundered across the arena to impale
bulls and Destroy Caledonian bears
to the amazed Spectators it was clear
that the emperor dimitian commanded
animals that were Superior to anything
Agricola might have encountered on the
Northern edge of Europe the Roman crowd
realized that the African continent was
extensive and its limits seemed endless
and so looking at their world maps the
Greeks and the Romans had realized that
the known Earth covered only a fraction
of the globe
Seneca wondered what undiscovered lands
might exist beyond the current reach of
Rome he remembered the arrival of the
sinhalese envoys which permitted distant
Sri Lanka to become a launching point
for Roman voyages out into the further
unknown
would the day come when the Empire could
complete its Atlantic conquest and reach
Across the Western Ocean to other
undiscovered lands
he wrote
there will come an age in future times
when the ocean shall unloose the bonds
of knowledge
when the whole vast Earth shall be
discovered tethis shall reveal new
worlds and Thule shall not be the limit
of the known lands
Roman civilization through the exploits
of conquest and commerce had discovered
accessed revealed and mapped the ancient
world as they knew it
but there was still much more
to be uncovered
[Music]
thank you